this is a cbs news special report
remembering prince philip
the duke of edinburgh queen elizabeth
sat alone during the funeral of her
husband
prince philip a choice that reflected
her trademark sense of responsibility
yes charlie we're looking now at the
queen she has stepped out of the bentley
and she's going into
st george's chapel you know tina it's
interesting this is the first time many
people are seeing her
following the death of her husband and
we know that she will have to sit alone
in the chapel the funeral services were
broadcast around the world on saturday
but the private ceremony itself included
just
30 close members of the family if
there's one thing that we know about
prince philip is that he really does not
like fuss and he made that known
when it came to planning his funeral as
well while it's certainly a
heartbreaking image
there's a good reason queen elizabeth
was seen by herself throughout the
service
where she said goodbye to her husband of
73 years prince philip
will be interred in the royal vault at
st
george's chapel which is where the queen
will also one day be
laid to rest even in these unfortunate
circumstances
buckingham palace continued following
kovid 19 procedures for the ceremony
which required members of each family to
sit separately
in saint george's chapel i know that
it's all part of covet protocols but
the fact that you're thinking she's lost
her husband of
you know 73 years she's going in to pay
final respects and that she has to sit
alone tina during the service
there's the queen sitting going to be
sitting alone
mourning this man who has been her
strength and stay as she said
her rock all the way through her life in
addition
prince harry was required to quarantine
upon arriving in the uk
from california he is in isolation on
quarantine
at frogmore cottage which is of course
the couple's uk
base so what sort of a homecoming is it
going to be for prince harry
well a deeply emotional one i think that
much we can be sure of
i'm sure that he's desperate to see his
grandmother the queen
but of course given what has happened
and what the queen is going through i
would imagine that she is
probably the first person he will want
to see
as soon as he's been given me all clear
it should also be noted that queen
elizabeth will celebrate her 95th
birthday next week which presumably
reinforced the necessity of these
strict protocols he worked closely with
the lord chamberlain's office
at buckingham palace to ensure that it
wasn't a blown-up
affair and that means that it won't be a
state funeral instead it will be a royal
ceremonial
funeral which will be a much more
private affair and while the royal
services at st
george's chapel felt the impact of the
coronavirus pandemic
we do know that prince philip wanted his
funeral to be an
intimate family gathering it's the same
place that harry and megan got married
it's
also a place that's considered a family
chapel rather than a public
gathering space and so this will really
give a chance for the royals
to remember his life in a very peaceful
and quiet way it also
avoids the the worries that the
government have over people congregating
during the time of the pandemic for
prince philip this is exactly
what he wanted it's the send-off that he
had asked for
you